i first met our next speaker
when she and my wife are working in the
same lab
she then became the ta for my class and
she's been a wonderful ta
and despite her long history of killing
even
office succulents she's managed to keep
an orchid alive since may of 2019.
please welcome monica
all right here we go
hi everyone i'm monica and today i'm
going to be talking to you guys about
how to prepare
and teach an r lesson so
why are we talking about teaching at a
conference where most people
are in industry perhaps not in academia
and thus say
not having to teach a programming course
to undergrads well
nobody is born knowing how to code all
programmers have to start
somewhere and we are all constantly
learning including events like this
if you ever find yourself responsible
for training someone else to program
from five minute informal tutoring to an
entire programming workshop or course
both you and your learners will benefit
from you knowing
how to teach in addition teaching well
promotes equity
while we have a long way to go towards
equal access and representation in
technical professions
any chance that you get to teach well is
a chance to level one of the many
uneven playing fields that people might
encounter on the way to a career in data
science or scientific computing
so if you teach effectively you can do
one small part to help lower
those barriers so
by the end of my talk i hope that you
will be able
to compare principles of backward lesson
design to principles of good coding
apply backward lesson design to outline
objectives
tests and content for an r lesson
implement formative coding assessment
check-ins to check learner understanding
during a lesson
and to describe benefits of narrated
live coding
so first let's get into backward lesson
design
but we're going to talk about code first
when we're writing code
be it a helper function a data
processing script or perhaps an entire
package
there's a common logical order that we
follow while doing this
first in coding we define our function
output what is it that we want our
function or whatever it is we're writing
to do or to produce then
we write our tests for that output how
are we going to know or be able to
verify
that our code is doing what we want it
to
and finally we write the code we can
only
write the code after we've defined what
it's supposed to do
and how we are going to know what it's
supposed to do
if you were to start writing your code
before you did those other two things
first then the code would just go
nowhere
backward lesson design takes that same
logic from coding
and applies it to teaching so if the
usual method of planning
lessons starts with choosing activities
or demonstrations to use and then
building a lesson around that
then if that's forward design then
backward design
in lesson planning involves following
steps in the following order
first we define our learning outcomes
what is it that we want learners to come
away with being able to do
then we define our evidence of learning
how are we going to know that our
learners have learned what we want them
to
and finally after we've done those two
things we build the lesson
so you'll notice that this looks a lot
like the logical process of coding
both coding logic and backward lesson
design aim to answer the following
questions
in order first what should our code
or our learners be able to do next
how will we know that they can do it how
will we verify this
and finally how are we going to equip
our learners and our code with the
ability to do what we want them to do
so you already know this logic lesson
planning is in this way
conceptually similar to writing code you
don't need to acquire a whole new
knowledge base from scratch in order to
be able to plan a lesson in r
you only need to learn how to relate
concepts from coding logic
to backward lesson design and that's
what we're going to do for the rest of
this talk
so next we're going to dig more into
each of these three steps of backward
design
as they might look in an r coding lesson
starting
with defining our learning outcomes so
defining a learning outcome
or a learning objective is conceptually
similar to defining the output of a
function
a script or an entire package that you
might write
it is the answer to the following
question
what will learners be able to do when
the lesson is finished
answer this question and that answer is
your learning objective so
when we're writing learning objectives
the most important thing for us to do to
make these objectives effective
is to be specific you have to be
specific when you're spelling out a
learning goal for it to be the most
effective
just like it's harder to write a
function when you haven't delineated
what you want it to do
it's harder to prepare a lesson when you
haven't outlined exactly what you want
it to teach
for example if we have this learning
objective
for a lesson that teaches novice r
programmers to be able to manipulate
and explore some data in r we can start
with this
it does outline the three packages we
expect learners to be able to do
but understand and explore data
is kind of vague and doesn't actually
say specifically what skills learners
will come away with
if we look at a more specific version of
this you'll notice that it is
first and foremost longer than the first
one and second
is much more broken out relative to the
first one and has specific
skills that learners will be able to do
like reshaping data
generating summary statistics and making
exploratory
scatter plots so next i'm going to talk
about some tips that you can use
to make your learning objectives a
little bit more specific and ideally
more effective
so the first thing you can do is to use
active verbs in your objective
in general if you start with a framing
like learners will be able to
use x to do why that'll generally get
you in the right place
and next if you're focusing on teaching
functions from a specific package
name the package and further if you're
focusing on just a few functions from
that package
name those functions and finally
more verbose is generally better for
learning outcomes because that'll help
you be sure
that you've explained with enough detail
exactly what
skills learners will be able to acquire
but of course don't go overboard
and as an aside you'll notice that i
opened this talk with a set of specific
active verb based learning objectives in
order to try to model
the types of backward design that you
can use in your teaching
in this talk so now that we've talked
about the first
step defining our learning outcomes
ready to move on
to defining evidence of learning
so how are we going to determine that
learners can indeed accomplish what the
learning objective
says that they can again in programming
and in teaching we must test
to confirm whether learners have
accomplished our learning objective
so in coding this can be as simple as
running your code multiple times under
different conditions to make sure that
the output looks right
or as elaborate as a full unit testing
system
so testing learners coding can happen in
a variety of different ways
from live fixing your code in front of
the person helping you during informal
tutoring
to coding an entire final project for a
semester-long class
in every case the only way that we can
know
that learners have reached the objective
is by testing their ability
to demonstrate it so
of course the final assessment after a
lesson is essential to determining
whether learners have met the objective
but by design it happens at the end of
the lesson
what have learners make a critical
mistake on the final assessment that
shows that they haven't actually reached
the objective
at that point the lesson is over and you
don't have any time left to get your
learners back on track
so this is where formative assessment
comes in
when you're teaching you have many
chances to assess learning
before the end of the lesson formative
assessments
are frequent and specific tests of
learner understanding
during teaching so formative assessments
in teaching
are like unit tests encoding in the
right in the following ways
first formative assessment and unit
testing both identify bugs in learner
understanding
or code functionality and next both of
them are built into the process and
should happen
in the process of learning or encoding
as opposed to just
at the very end and next both enable
in the moment debugging so you can check
learner understanding or code
functionality
like while it's going and next
both encourage more effective lesson
style
or coding style and finally if a
formative assessment
or if a unit test fails it's on the road
to your code or your learners
getting it right the next time you run
it so next we're going to talk a little
bit about how to implement these
formative assessments
so if we think back to the example
lesson that we started mocking up
teaching some functions from tidyr d
player and gg plot 2 to explore data
we can look at an example so the
function chains that are encouraged by
tidyverse style lend themselves really
well to formative assessments
formative assessment check-ins can be
built into a lesson after
every function in a pipe chain is
introduced
so if we look at this pipe chain let's
say that we're teaching towards the
second objective
where we calculate means and standard
deviations of the lengths and widths of
flower parts in the iris dataset
suppose we've already taught and checked
through the three
verbs that you see here in this pipe
chain
then perhaps we have just demonstrated
to learners how to use
named functions inside across and
summarize to generate
summaries of multiple input columns so
to check understanding we might give a
prompt
like this so here we've given specific
instructions to write
a single line of code from scratch to
summary
or to summarize um iris long that chunk
that we've already made
in this particular way so notice here
that our check in question explicitly
asks learners to produce
a single line of code only to do what
we're asking them to do
we can also instead of asking learners
to write out code from scratch
we can give them a line of code that
they need to edit to produce the desired
outcome
so this can also help us test byte size
concepts
so you can see here that we're asking
learners to
change the code that we have to get the
correct uh
suffix on their summarized outputs so
while this requires learners to generate
less code from scratch which
is sometimes what you want sometimes
what you don't it can be
faster to run during the lesson which is
the main benefit
so running formative assessment
check-ins of single lines of tidy code
is really handy for the following
reasons so
first learners get a natural pause after
each concept is introduced
which helps them solidify their
understanding before adding on more
information
and next when fewer lines of code are
tested at a time
ideally one at a time if different
learners make a mistake or have a
misconception
their errors are more likely to overlap
with one another that means that you the
instructor
when you're helping people can
demonstrate an error or fix it in front
of the entire group
instead of having to go around one by
one and help each person individually
that helps you go faster and it helps
your learners not have to sit and wait
for you to help someone else
and finally each check-in question can
be repeated until
every single person gets it right and
that ensures that when you get to the
next function
you're confident that everyone
understands everything that you've gone
through so far
so you won't have to do catch-up later
so all the check-ins that i've shown you
before are all written as either free
response or edit the code prompts that
do involve typing in console
in small groups this is generally the
most flexible way to implement these
formative assessment check-ins
because if they can write code that
works then they've hit the objective
but this does require that you the
instructor either trust that everyone
has run it correctly
or visually go around and check
everyone's code to make sure that it
actually does what it's supposed to
and this can be time consuming if you
have more than a few people
and there are other methods of formative
assessment that while less comprehensive
can scale a lot better to large groups
one of my favorite of these
is a multiple choice question so for
example
i can ask a question like this with two
options
each corresponding to a specific arm
markdown chunk that i'm going to show a
screenshot of
so for example learners would have to
vote
using an external polling app whether
chunk 1
or chunk 2 is going to return the output
that is requested
in the question then i the instructor or
in this case you
would be able to look quickly at the
percentage of responses that your
learners are making
and be able to tell what percentage of
learners are choosing the correct answer
and when written carefully multiple
choice questions are almost as good as
free response
what i mean by this is that distractor
answers or the incorrect
answers that you choose or that you show
can reveal specific mistakes and
misconceptions almost as well as free
response questions
if distractor answers are written to
look plausible
featuring commonplace mistakes maybe a
mistake you once made in the past
then you know that if learners choose
the correct answer
they're choosing the right answer
because they think it's right and not
because they've ruled out all of the
other answers to be incorrect
in that scenario someone could feasibly
get the right answer without
actually knowing why it's right and so
to that point i want to say briefly
don't write
trick distractor answers especially
those where you haven't actually taught
or explained to learners
why the incorrect answer would be
incorrect you want to make sure to test
learners only on skills that you've
shown them so far
otherwise it's a waste of time for them
and for you
so now that we've talked about how to
implement
assessment formatively during a lesson
to check learners understanding
we're now ready to build the lesson
itself so the nice thing about backwards
design is that once you've spelled out
your learning objectives
and your check-in tests ideally the
lesson itself is almost done
once you've laid out your assessments
you should be able to see exactly what
you need to demonstrate and explain
in order to equip learners with the
knowledge necessary to complete the
check-ins that you've laid out
so the core principle that i try to rely
on when crafting lessons
is to teach what you need to teach no
more
and no less this is gone abroad and
covers a lot of things so i'm going to
break it down for you
first it's important to calibrate to
learners incoming skill level
what do you think that learners should
be able to do already before they start
your lesson
start where learners already are so
don't re-teach stuff if you don't have
to
and teach everything that learners need
to know to hit your objective and this
means that you need to think through all
of the prereqs and make sure that either
you think learners already know them and
you check it to be sure
and that you're teaching everything else
next
allow your formative assessment
check-ins to break your lesson into
manageable chunks
if you have implemented the right number
and the right scope of these check-ins
each of these check-ins should serve as
the end to a bite-sized piece of lesson
about five
no more than 10 minutes and these bite
sizes or these bytes are a good size for
you
because you get to take a break from
talking and you get to check everyone's
progress
and they're a good size for learners
because they get to take a breather from
new information so that they can
solidify
what they've just learned and practice
it with the check-in
next teach less than you think you have
time for
an instructor teaching a lesson for the
first time is
often likely to find that that lesson
just takes longer than you originally
planned
and running out of time before you
finish pretty much 100
guarantees that your learners aren't
going to reach the learning objective
so finishing your content in time is key
and that doesn't mean go too fast
generally it means plan for less time
and let things go longer
i usually plan for about two-thirds of
the time that i
know that i'm gonna have when i time my
lesson out beforehand if i've never
taught it before
and then it usually comes out right but
your methods may vary
and next teach one way to do things
one of the great and terrible features
of r is that there's often
many different ways to code a particular
problem while some of these ways may be
more verbose or less generalizable than
others
sometimes you just get to two ways that
really differ just on personal taste
for example in the pivot longer chunk
that i showed before
where we're teaching people how to pivot
the iris data set
there's two different ways to split the
column names
one way is that we could use the names
sep under argument
of iris in order to break up column
names at the period
another way is that we could use names
pattern to use capture groups to break
up the two
sections of the column name so in
practice there are valid arguments for
using either one of these methods
using name sep to split as you can see
is less for both
but theoretically is less flexible than
if we were to use capture groups with
names
pattern just in case there are future
columns that don't all have
the period for example here we have to
think about
what is the learning goal if the primary
objective
is to learn about the two different
arguments that you can use with pivot
longer
then definitely show the two and talk
about the similarities and differences
between each strategy
but if the objective is only to be able
to pivot the data
at all and not necessarily to be able to
tell the difference between these two
specifications
then teach only the way that you want
students to be able
to do if comparing and contrasting
between two different coding methods
isn't part of your objective pick the
one you'd rather students be able to do
and stick with it that'll be much less
confusing to students and it'll save
you time so
now that we have talked about building
the lesson you're now ready to
deliver it so most likely you're gonna
teach
uh via live coding whether it be
standing up in front of a group of
people
and coding along with your computer
projected to a screen
um or a screen shared out to a large
group or if you're just one-on-one
coding on your computer next to someone
who's got say their laptop next to you
you demonstrate the code example on your
machine and then learners
follow along with what you've just done
so coding for an audience is a little
different than coding for yourself
you have to be intentional even if the
audience is just one person with their
computer next to yours
intentional live coding can spell the
difference between them following along
with you
versus not the single biggest tip i can
give
for any live coding context is to
narrate
everything that you click or type like
literally
everything every word every parenthesis
every quotation mark every hotkey
shortcut if you're clicking
say what you're clicking where it is on
screen spell it out
this helps in many respects for example
it helps learners orient themselves to
where they are in the r studio or
whatever other coding window that you're
using
especially if they're not super familiar
with like where menus or panes or
buttons are
um you spelling things out helps them
find things faster
and next it helps slow your pace down as
you're typing
so that learners are better able to
actually keep up with you because
more novice learners tend to just type
code a lot slower than more
experienced folks and next it helps
model effective coding technique
for example if you use a certain set of
hotkeys as shortcuts to make your life
easier
you want to pass that knowledge along to
learners as well and
if you make typos while you're coding if
you can narrate out
how you catch and fix those typos it
helps learners with a big implicit
objective of learning to code
which is catching their own mistakes and
i do want to note that with live coding
of course remember the lesson building
tip from before
to calibrate to your learner's existing
skill level um
if you know that your learners for
example already know where the help tab
is in our studio
you don't have to say you're going over
to the bottom right to click the help
tab if you do go over there
you can just say i'm going to the docs
and then go and click
so you can calibrate how much you
narrate to how much experience your
learners already have
but in general it doesn't hurt to err on
the side of narrating a little extra
so finally i'd like to go back over the
objectives
of our talk or of my talk now that we've
gone through everything
so by now i hope you are able to compare
principles of backward lesson design
to principles of coding apply that
design to outline in our lesson
from objectives to tests to content and
more specifically be able to write and
implement
these short check-ins to check learner
understanding and finally
be able to describe some benefits of
slow
narrated live coding so
with that knowledge thank you for your
attention i hope you go forth and feel
more equipped to teach effectively thank
you